I want to tell you about some research that my colleague, Mike,
George and I have done on the anti-malarial drug called
artemisinin.
Malaria is a truly dreadful disease that kills huge
numbers of people right across the planet.
And artemisinin is one of the most effective drugs at the moment
against malaria.
And we've had funding from the bill and Melinda Gates foundation,
and also from industry to try and make the process
for getting this drug more efficient and greener using
less toxic chemicals.
Malaria is a disease which is spread by mosquitoes.
If you're bitten by mosquitoes, carrying the plasmodium, parasite,
it injects this into your bloodstream. The parasite goes into your liver,
it multiplies,
and then bursts out of your liver and inhabits the red blood
cells,
where it destroys the hemoglobin stopping the courage of
oxygen around your body,
and eventually causing the red blood cells to effectively blow up.
And the debris can clog.
The Capella is and cause a really unpleasant death.
What is needed are low cost drugs that can treat people who are
infected.
And what you need to do is to zap these
parasites. You can also kill the mosquitoes,
but once you're infected it,
doesn't really much about the mosquitoes except they could spread the disease to
someone else or to missing or summits derivatives.
And here I've got a molecule or model about missing our
molecules that contain a bond with two oxygen atoms.
These oxygen atoms can be released in the form of hydrogen
peroxide, which I believe then kills the parasites.
Artemisinin is called artemisinin because it's extracted from the plant
called to mission and annual, which grows in tropical places.
For example, in Vietnam,
nobody's absolutely clear why the plant makes this material and they totally
make small amounts. So you need a lot of plants to extract the material out.
And at the moment,
the amount of material that can be made from plants is
sometimes just enough or if it is a bad crop, not enough.
So what is needed is a way of making this molecule efficiently
chemically.
Now you can see it's a pretty complicated molecule making this from scratch.
Although various skilled organic chemists have done it is
too expensive. There are too many steps needed.
So there has been some very elegant work done on modifying
yeast.
So the yeast can react with glucose or eat
glucose and turn it into a molecule which with some
chemical processes can be turned into artemisinin.
The two key steps that we've been looking at are the addition of these two
oxygen atoms so-called peroxide linkage here,
which is made by reacting the molecules
with oxygen in a special form called singlet oxygen.
If you've watched our video on oxygen,
you will know that normally oxygen has unpaired electrons and is
paramagnetic, it's attracted to maintenance,
but if you have oxygen in solution in the presence of sun
eyes, colored compounds, if you sign visible light,
these dyes can transfer the energy of the light.
They absorb to the oxygen and pair up the electrons,
but not for very long because the electrons quite quickly unpair.
So what you've got to do is to get this oxygen,
to react with your molecules before the electrons can unpair again.
Now the pharmaceutical companies developed a really neat
process in which they can make up to 60 tons a year of this compound.
The problem is that the process works really well,
but is still quite expensive.
And so we've been collaborating with them to do fundamental research,
to see if there are ways that we can make the process cheaper.
And we've had some really quite good success and we've come up with two
different ways and I'm not going to go into all the details,
but let me just give you a flavor.
The first thing is that when you're reacting oxygen,
which can make things burn,
you have to be very careful in your choice of solvent.
So we've done some experiments where we use as the solvent liquid
CO2 CO2 can't burn. So that makes it safer.
And we have quite a clever way, which you can read about in our paper,
in which we can make the dye molecules stick to solid
acid, because you also need an acid to catalyze the reaction.
So you can have a small tube with everything in it that you need,
your sign lights on it.
The precursor goes in and out of the bottom comes optimism.
The second experiments or set of experience we did really by
chance was to discover that we could make our [inaudible]
and the mixture of ethanol that's Ethal, alcohol and water.
Now you may think that's not very surprising,
but there is a strong feeling among chemists
that you can't do reactions of these singlet oxygen with paired
electrons in water,
because is really good at making the electrons unpaired again.
But it just turns out that the
water has other properties,
which pushed the molecules together and make them react faster.
But once you're working in water and ethanol,
you can then use less toxic acids. For example,
dilute sulfuric acid.
And the real beauty of the experiment is that we discovered that at
the end, if you evaporate of some of the ethanol,
the pure product precipitates out, and you can just filter off the crystals.
Normally you need to use a lot more solvents to purify the product once you've
made it and everything else,
the ethanol live distilled off the remaining water,
the acid and everything else can be recycled round and round.
The other possibility is that now we are beginning to understand the chemistry.
We could make other derivatives of ultimate listening already.
Some of the malarial parasites are becoming resistant to artemisinin.
And so if we can make new derivatives of it,
we may be able to zap the parasites even better.
The thing that really excites me is that especially
the,
to water is very simple and the product is so
pure that we actually took one crystal and went straight from the lab to
our crystallography lab. That's next door.
And they produce the crystal structure in an hour and a half.
And normally it takes time to grow crystals and get them ready and so
on. And here we did it really quickly.
The other thing is that I failed my exams,
my final exams as a students in organic chemistry.
And it was my colleague, Mike George,
who persuaded me that our group could actually do something useful for
malaria. And I'm really grateful to him and he's made it happen.
And if I take the liquid oxygen, you can say,
I can pull it right up here because oops,
it's not as magnetic as my keys,
but you can see there's a really big difference. It sticks to the magnet
so you can see it really is magnetic.